hello everyone and welcome to today's
panel presentation titled cell biology
applications using luminex flow
cytometry technologies this webinar is
part of the cell bio 2021
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
luminex for more information about
luminex please go to their website at
www.luminexcorp.com
let's get started before we begin i want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we want to encourage you
to participate first by communicating
with our other attendees using our new
live chat feature during the
presentation you can find this live chat
located at the top right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you'd like during
the presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on that help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speakers first katie
gillis a product manager and micro
capillary flow cytometry at luminix
corporation joining katie will be dr
stephanie burnell a product manager at
cellstream luminex corporation and
third brian hall a product manager at
the image flow cytometry in the luminex
corporation for a complete biography of
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top left of your screen
welcome to all three of you you may now
begin your presentations
hello and thank you for joining us today
i'm katie gillis product manager for the
luminex guava microcapillary flow
cytometry portfolio
i will be joined today by stephanie
brunell the product manager for the
selfstream flow cytometers as well as
brian hall the product manager for our
imaging flow cytometry platforms
we're excited to review some
applications for cell biology using the
luminex flow cytometry technology
luminex offers a variety of flow
cytometers for cell biology needs
ranging from our simplified easy to use
muscela analyzer to the ms image stream
imaging flow cytometers that combined
imaging with traditional flow cytometry
today we will be walking you through
applications for each of our cytometers
focused in cell biology
first up we'll be talking about the
guava muse and guava easy site systems
that have many applications for cell
biology ranging from simple count and
viability measurements to more complex
population identification as well as
mechanism of action studies
the guava muse and easy site instruments
use a patented micro capillary design to
provide simple and reliable results
the microcapillary eliminates the need
for sheath fluid on our systems
we pull the sample through the
microcapillary into the positive
displacement pump
that allows us to know exactly how much
volume has been acquired
which further allows us to
determine the absolute counts for each
sample
without the use of reference speeds
additionally
the microcapillary technology allows for
small sample sizes which preserves your
precious cellular samples and produces
low biohazardous waste
one assay we've developed and optimized
for cellular biology needs is our guava
viacount assay that measures cellular
counts and viability measurements for
your cellular samples
our simplified easy-to-use workflow
allows you to simply take our viacount
reagent add your cellular sample
incubate for five minutes at room
temperature
and acquire on the easy site or immune
systems
the proprietary by account reagent
contains two dna intercalating dyes
one that is membrane permeant
that will stain any cell that has a
nucleus allowing for discrimination
between nucleated cells and debris as
well as one that is membrane impermeant
that will distinguish between dead and
dying cells
additionally we've developed a software
platform for simple analysis and
acquisition of your samples with the
predetermined plots allowing for easy to
identify populations
as well as statistics that have been
optimized to highlight the key features
of this assay
as the graph shows on the lower left
corner of this
slide
we've compared the cellular
concentration versus the predicate
method
you can see that there is linear
correspondence
with an r-squared value and slope close
to 1.
additionally when we compared the
viability measurements using the
viacount assay to a predicate method
as shown by the bar graph
similar results were obtained
lastly one key feature is the fact that
our assay distinguishes dead and dying
cells unlike traditional triparam blue
methods which highlight just live and
dead cells
so shown here is an example with healthy
shells healthy cells as well as
overgrown cells
as you can see the overgrown dot plot
shows
a dead and dying population
in the middle here
that sample was then compared to an
annexin 5 assay to compare population
percentages as you can see the
population percentages
for the annex and five assay match those
shown with the viacount assay
the muse and easy site technologies
provide pre-validated kits that allow
for the identification and enumeration
of both whole blood and pbmcs
these assays are mix and read and take
as little as 10 microliters of sample
the sample is mixed with one of our
pre-formulated kits and acquired on our
muse or easy site instruments
each instrument has a predefined
acquisition and analysis template that
allows the user for simplified
acquisition and analysis
the guava counting assays highlighted
here
utilize our proprietary mix of dyes to
exclude cellular debris and identify the
count
of nucleated as well as
debris
we also identify
viable dead and dying cells
unlike assays that utilize trip and blue
the guava counting assay uses uses a dna
intercalating dye that indicates any
membrane disruption and can be an in
early indication of cellular distress
the guava immunology assays
are developed to provide to provide the
user with cd4 cd8 or b cell
concentrations
and the percentages of the in the
overall lymphocyte population
these are also mix and read assays that
can be combined to determine
all of the various populations
results for the muse immunology assays
are shown here the muse immunology
assays provide absolute counts total
lymphocyte counts and population
percentages
based on the total lymphocyte population
for either cd4 cd8 or b cells
two of the assays are highlighted here
the dot plots in the upper left
highlight the results for either the cd4
assay or the cd8 assay
the lymphocyte population is shown on
the y-axis for both plots and either the
cd4 or the cd8 population is shown in
the x-axis
very clear separation for the lymphocyte
populations is shown for both assays as
well as clear separation for the cd4 as
well as the cd8 populations
a comparison of the cd4 counts for a
predicate method versus the mu cell
analyzer is shown in the graph on the
right
you can see that based on the linear
response that is shown
based on both the slope as well as the r
squared value
that comparable results are seen on both
on the mu cell analyzer
lastly we evaluated the cv
results for the count the percent
lymphocyte as well as the count for the
total population
these results were compared for three
operators across three instruments
running four samples in triplicate
you can see that the cvs for all of
these populations were well below five
percent
in addition to being able to count your
cell samples on the guava easy site and
mu systems we've developed a few assays
to assess cellular health three of those
assays are the guavanexin mitodamage and
cell cycle assays
the guavanexan assay combines an xn5pe
with 7aed
for determination of live
early mid late apoptotic cells as well
as dead cells
the assay uses an anexin 5pe which
evaluates phosphatidylserine exposure as
well as 7ad which allows for assessment
of cells whose membrane are no longer
intact
an example staining is shown in the dot
plot here
additionally we show a dose response
curve using the the nexan assay on
jerket cells that have been treated with
styrosporine
with different concentrations
the the graft clearly shows that the
anexin 5 response increases with the
higher
inducer concentration as well as higher
percentage of cells showing cellular
death
one assay that takes things a step
further is our mito damage assay which
we'll go into a little bit more detail
in the next slide that evaluates in
addition to a nexon five and seven aed
populations the mitochondrial membrane
potential
this assay shows clear separation for
these very critical aspects of cellular
health
the last essay i want to highlight right
here is our guava cell cycle assay which
looks at dna content for your cells the
histogram plot shows an example staining
for our cell cycle assay which uses pi
to assess the dna content
additionally the bar graph shows an
example on jerket cells and pc3 cells
that were left untreated or treated for
cellular arrest
one final area i would like to show
today is related to mechanism of action
studies during drug discovery
development and deployment
here we show an example of the mida
damage assay that combines three
cellular health markers
to assess changes in mitochondrial
membrane potential apoptosis or cellular
death
this example deploys all three cell
health markers simultaneously
medicine spread detects changes in
mitochondrial membrane potential and is
shown as a downward shift in
fluorescence
indicating a loss of the membrane
potential
apoptosis is detected using the nexon-5
which indicates phosphatidylserine
exposure
lastly cellular death is detected using
7ad
staining
where there's a loss of membrane
integrity integrity
dot plots shown here show example
stainings for the assay on jerk hats
clear separation for each population is
seen
the two bar graphs show dose responses
for either a topicide
a known topopa isomerase inhibitor or
styrosporin a known protein kinase
inhibitor
and the corresponding population
percentages
with depolarized populations shown in
red apoptotic populations shown in
yellow yellow
and cellular death population shown in
blue
the bar graph is shown for both compound
depolarization and apoptosis
see similar percentages but little
cellular death was seen additionally at
this time point stereoscoring shows a
much larger shift in depolarization and
apoptosis when compared to atopicide
therefore in addition to counting an
immune cell subpopulation identification
the guava platforms can be used to
evaluate and assess drug mechanism of
actions and effects
thank you
now i will turn it over to stephanie
next we'll talk about the amnes cell
stream a camera-based flow cytometer
which uses time-delay integration ccd
technology
the cell stream system is a benchtop
camera-based flowcytometer built on the
amnest technology similar to the image
stream an image gallery is used to
visualize objects in flow the cell
stream is a high throughput compact
system with a small footprint and it
allows for modular and flexible upgrades
the high sensitivity of the slow
cytometer allows for traditional flow
assays as well as small particle
experimentation
the cell stream can be used for
traditional assays such as
immunophenotyping
in this particular study we performed a
16 color amino phenotyping of major
lymphocytes and myeloid subsets in human
pbmcs and whole blood
as you can see we easily resolve all
expected populations as well as
populations identified by dim markers
such as t cell subsets the t cells were
characterized into distinct subsets
including naive effector effector memory
central memory activated and regulatory
t cells
in this study we use the cell stream to
monitor the phosphorylation of signal
transducer and activator of
transcription or stat proteins which are
transcription factors that migrate to
the nucleus upon phosphorylation and
alter gene expression
stack proteins are known to be
stimulated by certain cytokines such as
interleukins
stats 3 5 and 6 which have been
associated with prognosis and cancer and
other malignancies were simultaneously
monitored
in cd4 positive t cells in these
experiments
whole blood was stimulated with
interleukins 2 4 and 6. red blood cells
were lysed and the remaining leukocytes
were analyzed with antibodies against
phosphorylated stat proteins
specifically phosphorylated stat 3
5 and 6. the gating strategy is shown
here for identifying cd4 positive cells
the phosphoflow results show that il4
stimulated stat6 as in the top panel and
you can see a shift in fluorescence
outlined by the box
2 stimulated stat 5 as seen in the
second row
and il-6 stimulated stat 3 in the third
row
on the bottom part of this slide you can
see a mix of interleukins phosphorylated
all the stats we investigated the
unstimulated blood is shown in gray and
this is the negative control
next we'll shift gears and talk about
extracellular vesicles or evs
evs are membrane derived structures that
include exosomes micro vesicles and
apoptotic bodies
exosomes range from about 30 nanometers
to 100 nanometers
exosomes have been shown to transfer
molecules between cells and have the
potential to transfer signals between
cells
exosomes are released under normal
physiological conditions however
exosomes are also believed to serve as
mediators in the pathogenesis of
neurological vascular hematological and
autoimmune diseases as well as cancer
quantifying and characterizing evs is
challenging due to their small size
high magnification microscopy such as em
can be used to analyze ebs however it's
very low throughput
additionally pmt-based flow cytometers
have a difficult time detecting ebs
since they are not highly sensitive
imaging flow cytometers that use a
charge-coupled device or ccd camera can
detect evs such as the cell stream
in order to immunophenotype evs we
follow this workflow using red blood
cells or rbcs and platelet-derived evs
the evs are obtained from celarcus
biosciences the rbcs and platelets were
washed and treated with a calcium
ionophore to induce fasciculation
the vesicles were then isolated via
centrifugation
the resulting evs were labeled with
either an
anti-cd235 antibody with pe
or a cd41 antibody with apc
the labeled ev samples were serial
diluted as shown here
samples were then acquired on the cell
stream for three minutes per sample with
100
laser power
all proper controls were run including
antibody only buffer only and detergent
controls
these controls were run exactly as the
eb samples
samples were run in duplicate on three
cell stream instruments
shown here in the top row is the gating
strategy for identifying the potential
ev populations for both the rbc and
platelet-derived evs
the population ranges from about 50 to
200 nanometers with a peak around 100 or
120 nanometers with the platelet evs
having a larger tail
the bottom row shows the serial dilution
data the 1 to 60 dilution on the far
left has a significant amount of
coincident events so that concentration
is too high
ev concentration was measured for each
of the dilution controls
dilution controls were used to check for
swarming
swarming occurs when multiple evs are
detected at once or as a swarm
and not as single objects which is how
we want to detect tvs
as you can see here both sets of
dilutions show a linear decrease in the
potential ep population using the cell
stream for both the pe and the apc
labeled evs
additionally the ev mean intensity was
measured for the dilution controls for
both p e and apc the ev mean intensity
remained consistent for each dilution
the dilution controls shown here
indicate that the potential eb
population consists of single objects
in ev research controls and dilutions
are just as important as your samples
since these help determine what is
artifact or background noise and what is
a true ev
shown here are the data for the pe
positive ev samples and controls and the
corresponding serial dilutions for all
as you can see the average of objects
per microliter for the ev samples are
significantly different from all of the
controls for all dilutions
the low concentration measured for these
background controls validates the ev
population
similar to the pe data the apc-positive
evs and corresponding controls show a
significant difference and therefore the
ev population is validated here as well
since the cell streams has such high
sensitivity and can easily detect evs is
a great system for investigating ev
cargo as well
the data shown here are from a study
investigating evs derived from human
embryonic kidney cells
these evs were stained with the
exagloprotein
and exoglo rna labeling reagents to
detect protein and rna cargo on the evs
on the left part of this slide the plots
and histograms show the potential ev
population
positive for protein cargo colored in
grain and rna cargo colored in orange
on the top right dilution series data
show that for both protein and rna
positive evs
there is a linear decrease in signal
with extremely low background validating
the labeled ev population
on the bottom right we see stable main
fluorescence of the positive events for
evs with cargo in the cereal dilutions
protein cargo is shown in green and rna
cargo is shown in orange
the same laser intensities were used for
all samples
this indicates the measurement of
individual evs and not swarms of ebs
in summary the cell stream provides
unparalleled flexibility and performance
with excellent resolution and detection
of target populations including small
particles such as evs
and it offers high throughput sampling
high adaptability for current and future
needs all in a benchtop system
as you've heard from myself katie and
brian luminex offers a wide range of
flow cytometry products that meet most
research needs as you can see in the
table here we offer a variety of
instruments ranging from our cell
analyzer to our imaging platforms
please contact us with any questions
about our versatile flow cytometers
thank you for listening to our
presentation
thank you stephanie for that great
presentation on the cell stream this is
brian hall i'm the product manager for
the amnest imaging portfolio
and i'd like to
wrap up our presentation today by
talking about the image stream imaging
flow cytometer and some of the
application used to study cell biology
as you know cell biology is a
general term that refers to a diversity
of different types of expertise and
applications that might be done
all evolving around cell analysis
many researchers are interested in
looking at bacteria and virus
infiltrating cells or
some may be simply interested in
measuring a
protein expression or surface protein
expression while others might be
interested in looking at cell to cell
interactions
there are a number of tools that can be
used to look at these different aspects
of cell biology and traditionally this
research would be done using flow
cytometry
cytometry is a great tool because it
collects large numbers of events it
allows you to look at surface expression
and in some cases phosphorylation state
of different proteins
and critically uh flow cytometry allows
you to physically sort cells and do
downstream analysis on purified
populations of cells however it doesn't
have any type of morphological
information
involved with the data set so
traditionally if you wanted to look at
cell morphology you would use
fluorescent microscopy or confocal
microscopy
microscopy is great because it gives you
information on the shape and the size of
the cell
but it tends to be less quantitative
than
uh flow cytometry because you're looking
at smaller cell numbers
the image stream is really uniquely
suited to address both of these
strengths and allow you to collect
images at very high throughput so the
image stream is an imaging flow
psychometer
it's essentially collecting
tens of thousands of images per second
uh and allows you to collect large image
databases that allow you to learn more
about your about your sample and so it's
really combining the strengths of
microscopy with the high throughput of
flow cytometry it allows you to make
novel discoveries learn the mechanisms
of actions and essentially get your
science right
now by combining these two technologies
there are a number of advantages to
doing image flow cytometry
um one of them is that you can go
collect uh data simultaneously by that
we mean that you can multiplex your
experiments so that you could do a uh
apoptosis experiment in conjunction with
a
amino phenotyping or other type of
multiplexed assays in this example you
can look at the cell surface marker
expression and combine that with side
scatter or cell health analysis
you can look at where the fluorescence
is located is it is it located uh is it
co-localized or are the fluorescent
markers staining individual sub-cellular
organism organelles you can also look at
just general markers brightness and
quantify the intensity level you can
also look at colocalization of proteins
so there's a diverse
number of ways in which you can
multiplex your data uh and using all 10
colors
as well as the bright field and side
scatter information you can learn a lot
about your cell sample
another advantage to imaging flow
cytometry is it allows you to verify
your results and by that we mean you can
look at the histograms and dot plots
that are associated with your data set
you can click on those dots and see a
picture of the cell so in this top
example you can not only quantify the
number of cells and have one two or
three particles phagocytosed but you can
click on these bins and verify that in
this case this image has two
particles phagocytosed and this one has
one this one has three
you can also look at marker expression
and by looking at the double positives
you can identify cells that are
potentially
t cells binding to antigen presenting
cells as in this image or is the
fluorescence overlapping just on this on
the cell surface of one large cell so it
allows you to really understand what's
going on physiologically with your
samples
and finally the am this team has
developed a number of software tools
that allow you to really investigate
this high parameter data set
using our
regular analysis software ideas you can
look at
thousands of different parameters
that look at all types of morphological
information
uh
however we've developed new tools such
as machine learning and the amnes ai
software that allows you to use uh convo
deep learning using convolutional neural
networks to
use the to essentially train the
computer to go in and identify unique
phenotypes of your specific experiment
so you can customize the analysis based
on your individual research
so as you can see there's really
limitless applications that you can
use the image stream with this the
strength of combining the imagery with
the flow cytometry data really allows
you to go in and investigate a number of
different uh different
cell-based assays and look at
look at things like cell signaling
internalization
co-localization
measuring
stem cell differentiation looking at
unique cell types such as
algae and ocean water
or finding very rare cells such as
circulating tumor cells so there's a
number of different applications you can
use the image stream for
so to give you a brief overview of how
the instrument works
cells are fluorescently labeled in an
eppendorf tube
they are
hydrodynamically focused here in a
quartz cuvette we use multiple laser
lines to excite that fluorescence
we also use a brightfield illuminator to
eliminate bright field imagery from
behind so we're essentially collecting
multi-mode imagery simultaneously
at rates of 10 000 objects per second
images can be captured at 20 40 or 60x
imaging objective and that image is
projected through a series of pets fall
lens sets to what we call the spectral
decomposition element
and this filter stack essentially
displays the images in
spatially discrete regions on a ccd
detector
our ccd camera is operated in time delay
integration mode which effectively
allows us to increase the photonic
sensitivity and maintain a 0.33
micron per pixel image resolution so
it's very high image quality with very
high photonic sensitivity and again this
is collecting 10
fluorescent channels
two bright field channels and a side
scatter image so it's 12 parameter data
that's simultaneously collected on each
of your events
this is an example of the type of
imagery that it produces this is a 40x
image
of thp1 cells labeled with nf kappa b
and green and direct 5 labeling the
nucleus
we capture these images
using the camera but critically these
images are pixelated so in other words
we effectively have not only the total
intensity of the cell but we have
thousands of sub cellular measurements
so we can look at and effectively map
different regions of the cells so we
have an intensity value with an x y
coordinate of each of the pixels in the
image and we can then use computer
algorithms to go in and interrogate
those images to
look at unique morphology such as spot
formation
these images also maintain spatial
registry so that we can overlay these
images on top of each other and look at
co-localization
look at where the fluorescence is is
located is it in the nucleus or the
cytoplasm and also quantify different
morphological aspects of the images
so there's a direct link between the
images and the data as they're
represented with the dot plots and the
histograms if we look through an image
gallery here these images are randomly
collected but we have a region of small
cigalette cells we would typically map
to a dot plot here the singlet cells are
in the upper left hand corner we also
have large singlets
we all mapping here and we have
conjugate cells that map to this lower
aspect ratio region
when we look at all 20 30 000 events in
the data file we can click on a given
dot in this image and see its
corresponding
picture and vice versa we can click on
the picture and see where it's located
in the dot plot
taking this to the next level though we
can also look at different surface
marker immune
phenotypes so here are the cd19 cells
and the cd3 cells the t cells are
identified there but looking at the
double positive population we can look
at cells that are involved in immune
synapse formation
again
looking at
thirty thousand forty thousand events we
can characterize and count how many of
these cells in this sample have formed
immune synapses
now the first example that i'd like to
talk about is measuring chemotaxis in
monocytes after treatment with a
chemoattractant mcp1 mcp1 is known to
cause monocytes to migrate to the site
and of inflammation
it's also used in drug development where
um you know a patient might have an
autoimmune disease so you can inhibit
this this pathway and
prevent
prevent monocytes from
from causing a disease through
self-recognition
in this experiment we're going to treat
these
monocytes with
mcp1 to induce a
change in their overall morphology
and then we're going to
surface label the monocytes with cd14
collect 5000 events in the image stream
we're going to try and quantify shape
change using an algorithm that we call
circularity
circularity is a good example of how
you can use quantitative morphology to
really characterize the overall shape of
your cells so in the untreated sample
you can see that most of the monocytes
are spherical
have a round
presentation
if you look after treatment with mcp1
many of the cells have this elongated
shape or some of them are trilobes so
what we want to do is create a feature
that can characterize that dramatic
change in the overall shape
again the
feature that we're going to use is
called circularity
circularity i think is easy to
understand it's effectively the average
radius divided by radial variance so you
could imagine if you have these spokes
of a wheel
and you have a perfectly round cell and
you line them up from end to tip when
there's very little variation and the
total number of radii formed in that
circle
you must have a circular shape because
all the radii are the same however if
the cell is
has an oblong shape or in this case has
three lobes there's going to be a lot of
radial variance there
that's essentially how the circularity
feature works is it characterizes how
round the cell is versus how
oddly shaped it is and and that's also
an indication of mcp1 which effectively
causes a loss in circularity
looking at my sample set you can see
that in the untreated sample most of the
cells have this this round phenotype
about nine percent of the cells have an
oblong phenotype
but if i look after treatment with mcp1
you can see that about 60 percent of
this cells
are showing a
oblong phenotype meaning that they've
responded to mcp1
and are effectively launching an immune
response to the site of inflammation
now the next experiment i'd like to talk
about is looking at t cell antigen
presenting cell conjugate formation and
then measuring nf
nf kappa b translocation to the nucleus
as an indication of t cell activation
and if kappa b is a transcription factor
so when it's translocated to the nucleus
you know that these t cells are
transcribing genes
we want to look at the specifically in
the t cell to really verify that it's
activated when it's bound to the antigen
presenting cell
the problem is is that antigen
presenting cells also have nf kappa b so
what we need to do is isolate the t cell
and just look at the nf kappa b within
that specific cell
now in this experiment we're using a
transgenic mouse that has a tcr that is
specific to ovipeptide such that when we
treat the thymus cells from these mice
with ovipeptide we effectively activate
the t cells to bind antigen presenting
cells
and launch an immune response so we're
using antigen presenting cells from a
different mouse mixing them together to
get t cell apc cell conjugates then
we're going to measure the
activation as a result of n of kappa b
translocation
so to stain these cells these cells are
fixed and permeabilized and
stained with nf kappa b as well as 7aad
to identify the nucleus and they had
previously been stained with a cd8 to
identify the t cells in cd45 to identify
the antigen presenting cells
we're going to collect around 30 000
events because this can be a rare event
looking for for just those few cells
that form conjugates and we're going to
try and measure an f kappa b
translocation
now the first step in this process is to
identify the conjugates so you can see
in the upper left-hand corner
of this plot
there are the single cells and i can
verify that region by looking at the
images that are in this region up here
in the upper left r3 identifies the cell
conjugates
and what we want to make sure is that
we're not getting coincident conjugates
so using a cd45 versus cd8 dot plot we
can identify t cell binding to antigen
presenting cells that it's about 80 to
90 percent you can see in fact there is
one t cell one apc cell here so we've
identified conjugate formation using a
combination of aspect ratio and
intensity
the next step is to look at nuclear
localization and to introduce that
subject i need to bring up a
subject called a mask and what a mask
does is it's how the computer identifies
a region of interest and
tells the algorithm sort of where to
look for different fluorescence
intensities so
in this example here you can see here's
the mass that masks the entire cell so
this would tell me the overall cell size
if i wanted to characterize that i could
erode that mass to look at the
cytoplasmic area of that cell but if i
subtract the cytoplasmic region from the
the total cell mass i can identify a
thin mass that identifies the membrane
of that cell so for example if i just
wanted to look at membrane fluorescence
i could use this mass to quantify total
intensity there
there are mass that identify the regions
in between cells there are masks that
look at dark spots or light spots
and there are masks that look at
different components within the image
and so there's a diverse array of masks
that you can use there's approximately
19 and all of these masks you can use a
boolean logic to combine the masks or
subtract them so there's a lot of
different ways you can look at some
cellular regions
so for this particular experiment what
we want to do is use a mass to identify
the antigen presenting cell and the
seven
aad fluorescence we can then take the
apc mask and subtract it from the
nuclear mask and identify the nucleus of
just the t cell so this is the 7ad and
not cd45 mask
again use that mask and calculate what
we call similarity and what similarity
does is just looks at how much of that
fluorescence is inside the nucleus
versus inside the cytoplasm so if i look
at a very low dose of ovipeptide you can
see that most of the t cells are not
fully activated and that the nf kappa b
resides in the cytoplasm as indicated by
the imagery
i look at a high dose of a peptide
and look at those images we get an
increase to about 32 response of 50
nanomolar ova and if i look at the
imagery you can see that the nf kappa b
is in the nucleus of the t cell
but not of the antigen presenting cell
it also has nf kappa b but it's located
in the cytoplasm so here using this this
masking and different features
we're able to isolate the t cells in
this single event and look at the the
spatial distribution of transcription
factor f kappa b
it's a very really good use of imaging
flow cytometry
so using the similarity feature i can
then calculate a ec 50 curve i can do a
dose and a time
course with that
and look at the
the temporal interactions of of you know
when and if kappa b is translocating
uh in these activated t cells
so that just is a high level overview of
some of the applications um using
imaging flow cytometry uh there's
diverse array of applications that you
can use cell signaling
internalization cell cell interaction
spot counting looking at unique uh
cell types such as parasites or ocean
water
looking at rare cells imaging
circulating tumor cells or very rare
cells that show up in your sample
so there's a lot of different types of
applications that you can use the image
stream for that helps you make novel
discoveries learn the mechanism of
action and essentially get the science
right
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your time please if you have any
questions type them in and we will
respond to you through email
thank you very much for your time during
this presentation and i look forward to
hearing from you all again in the future
thank you
you